des vaches dont les produits laitiers
font la fierté de cette ferme de
normandie et des poulets qui sont vendus
dans de nombreux marchés à travers le
pays une activité agricole diversifié
qui se fait désormais à fort prix moi ça
fait 40 ans que je dirige exportations
s'est jamais arrivé d'avoir suivi à
subir des talos augmentation bien sûr
des prix du carburant mais aussi de la
zone utilisés pour fertiliser les champs
un camion d'azov coûtait 5000 euros
aujourd'hui en voyant vos vingt mille
donc il nous en faut choix ses treize
camions par an donc c'est colossal à
l'augmentation en écolo ça déséquilibre
complètement la trésorerie de
l'entreprise
cet agriculteur n'a pas le choix cette
pression se reflète sur les prix de sa
gamme de produits petite augmentation
des podiums gour le poulet entier lui a
déjà connu de hausse cette année c'est
une chose que je n'aurais jamais on
ajuster les prix une fois par an et là
on six mois on va être obligé de le
faire deux fois et c'est peut-être pas
fini
à 25 km de la ferme au marché de dieppe
la hausse des coûts de production se
fait sentir sur les factures des clients
forcément ils comprennent pas ce que
tours aux commandes de toute façon donc
on est obligé qu'on peut pas rester à
vendent à perte sondage après sondage
les enjeux liés au coût de la vie à
l'inflation et au pouvoir d'achat sont
la priorité des électeurs français
depuis des mois des préoccupations qui
ont pris de l'ampleur depuis le début de
la guerre en ukraine et des aliments
coût du carburant des phénomènes qui se
transpose directement dans les paniers
au marché de dieppe ici le samedi
l'occasion de faire le plein dans ray
mais le reste de la semaine il faut
surveiller les dépenses on fait très
attention au budget il ya un petit peu
être privations
comment dirais-je on dépense un peu plus
ce week-end mais sinon pour faire
attention
pour contrer ces hausses le gouvernement
français a offert un rabais à la pompe
le président sortant promet aussi une
prime aux travailleurs une réponse
insuffisante selon cette femme qui
évoque une réputation qui colle à la
peau des manuels matran auprès de
certains électeurs s'est désolé de dire
mais m'accrocher les très très riches
c'est donc bien sûr qu'il va y avoir un
impact dans cette région où se côtoient
terre et mer le phénomène ne connaît pas
de frontières
[Musique]
paquita classe en vente en ville les
poissons et fruits de mer que son mari à
pêcher malgré la hausse du carburant
elle assure tout faire pour que l'impact
sur les prix soient limitées on est un
petit bateau on se dit que si un peu de
pêche là pas trop loin ça nous évite de
faire de la route donc ça fait moins de
consommation et puis bah pour l'instant
on tient mais on ne sait pas combien de
temps on verra
paquita ne sais pas si l'élection
apportera des solutions elle constate en
tout cas que malgré les difficultés ses
clients continuent de s'arrêter à son
kiosque pour s'offrir de petits plaisirs
je vois quand même il ya des gens ils
sont contents de pouvoir faire plaisir
en achetant de la coquille saint jacques
ils le disent des fois bon bah allez on
se fait plaisir on en prend ici rafale
bouvier auclair radio canada a dit m